john you you took the outfit off i did i
did i uh
it's very difficult to go number two in
it and i found out the hard way so i
just needed some emergency dry cleaning
because i may have grabbed my pants i am
very sorry to hear that oh that's cool
it's cool it's dry cleaner's fault i'm
not
washing it don't worry about it true dry
cleaners problem no not yours not yours
it's connected so it went up the shirt
too so
oh i'm sorry i hope everything works out
you know
i'll the costume will be back sounds
like a mess in there
three two what are you guys doing
what you were here to save you you were
gonna save
me this is a really good plan too well i
can go back inside and you can still do
it okay so for anyone who might need
clarification joel maybe you can take
this one between
suicide squad and now there's the
suicide squad how do you describe
this film well this is you know it's not
really a sequel
it's uh it's not really a reboot it's
kind of its own thing you know it lives
in its own universe
and and and you know this is james
gunn's the suicide squad
any questions this isn't your first uh
suicide
team up as rick flagg how did you
approach coming back into this character
for a second time around and what
conversations did you and james have
about whether or not it's the same guy
yeah so it was it was strange because or
strange it was unusual
you know i've come back to characters
several times you know both in films and
in tv you know you have a break and then
you come back and it's usually a really
good experience because the character
kind of marinates in you
and and you come back and you feel like
you're you're doing more
but using less energy in a way but here
it was
different because i actually felt like i
needed to reinvent the character and and
reading james's script
it was a different version of it so i
had my first conversation with him and
i told him that i didn't want to feel
bound by what i did in the first film
[Music]
for this one i'm just gonna go and kind
of
recreate them i loved rick flag in this
movie so good
um and john you are so
funny and i feel like i knew this like
train wreck i was like oh my god john
cena's so funny but it just seemed like
you had
so much fun playing peacemaker
and i read that your homework was not to
read anything at all
about this character so how did you find
this kind of character within and what
was your approach
well i think it's trusting the people
around you uh james told me specifically
not to read the mythology and i
appreciate that because
he said he wanted to craft his his own
uh narrative but at the same
time i still did my homework i knew
about the uniform i tried on costume
uh i kind of developed my own direction
that i wanted a peacemaker to go
and the first day of shooting it was put
to an abrupt hall james is like no
i was thinking more lee army full metal
jacket uh general patton
you know very glorified war hero type
freedom fighter sort of thing
uh patriot and then james is like no
he's a douchey captain america he's just
like a broly douchey captain america
and with i guess it's the ability for me
not to try to argue the point of yeah
but i was thinking this and i've done
all this work for this at that one
sentence i threw all that work away and
was just like yeah i get that
so it was him but it was my ability to
be like
yo okay screw all that prep we're going
in a completely different
direction and i got to do it now because
i've done two takes that he doesn't like
and
i need to do a take of this new guy this
new
douchey burn captain america and douchey
captain america that's that's where
you're like oh yeah got it
i love that no joel
no i just said you know that's that's a
clear image i think
i think in one sentence everybody gets
that yeah
it's true it's true i i feel like i know
exactly what that is and it's peacemaker
honestly
um we're so excited for the future of
peacemaker by the way i know there's
probably not a lot you can say because
people need to see the movie and get the
context but
i know you already filmed the series
what was that kind of episodic
experience like with that character and
do you think we'll get oh no no there's
a ton
i can say it's just warner's and hbo max
will storm through this door and string
me up from the ceiling
so i can't say
anything at all uh i know that i think
people will get an idea of what they're
in for when they see the suicide squad
and the best way to explain it is the
suicide squad is a
two hour and twenty minute film that
dives into 25 main characters
peacemaker is an eight episode episodic
for hbo max
about peacemaker and you're gonna get to
lean into those nuances and peacemakers
surroundings so
you get you do get more of that so if
you like what you see
it's it's a great extension do you think
we'll get multiple seasons
you know i i have stopped in my life
trying to speculate what will be
especially what's out of my control
uh i gave my all to the suicide squad
we're here promoting the best we can
i really hope audiences enjoy the movie
we wrapped on peacemaker the series
uh i'll promote that the best that i can
and if audiences enjoy it they're in
control that not me
so i'll do absolutely all i can i left
my heart and soul in the lens
i won't look back on and be like man i
wish i had done
so that's kind of how i approach
opportunity in life
uh rather than speculate on like man
we're gonna get six seasons out of this
do the best you can with what you have
in the now
and let all that stuff be on my control
takes shape
true true good advice good advice so uh
john i want to ask you on that note what
your immediate next chapter looks like
because i get the sense that you're
gonna
focus on wwe what can you tell us and
and how do you feel about them next
chapter is in
six hours i'll be in a wwe ring here in
pittsburgh pennsylvania and then i'll do
the same tomorrow night in louisville
and i'll do the same in kansas city
uh we're heading in minneapolis
milwaukee and detroit
and then i'm gonna go to the suicide
squad premiere uh
and then uh back to the wwe for a
roundup in florida and then in arizona
and vegas at summerslam
uh do vegas uh release vacation friends
on
hulu and then head over to the uk to
film argyle uh come on back hopefully do
some more wipeout and you never know i
really can't stay away from wwe so i may
sneak in there for
the holiday season i don't know not too
busy just hard-working man
um and we're all we're all busy i i love
all these things and i
i i take them one when i say i'm doing
all this i literally
am specifically just doing that this is
a very rare occasion
where the two are crossbred but like i'm
focused on what i do when i do it
and i do one thing at a time and then
just move on to the next thing and
i'm a focused hummingbird focused
hummingbird i love that
guys thank you so much for your time i
love the movie so much i'm doing my
reading so
oh thank you okay thanks guys
take care